hello everyone and welcome to the
mindscape podcast
I'm your host Sean Carroll and I have a
confession to make
namely I have made mistakes over the
course of my career as a scientist and a
writer for that matter over the course
of my life as a human being when faced
with decisions I have sometimes made the
wrong choice maybe you have too and
happily we have on today's podcast the
perfect person to talk about this idea
that people make mistakes dr. Carol
Tavares who's one of the world's experts
not on making mistakes or the ways that
we make mistakes but on what happens
after we make mistakes in a masterful
book that she wrote with her co-author
Eliot arenson
called mistakes were made but not by me
why we justify foolish beliefs bad
decisions and hurtful acts dr. Tavis
talks about the idea of cognitive
dissonance and how we are forced by
cognitive dissonance to come up with
excuses and justifications for the
mistakes that we make we might like to
imagine that we are perfectly rational
reasonable beings but the psychological
truth is very much the opposite of that
we make up reasons why something was the
right choice after all or why we
couldn't had any other option but to
make it cognitive dissonance theory
explains why we do this and in some
sense it's the mother of all cognitive
biases it helps us understand why we're
not the perfect rational reasonable
people that we pretend to be and Carol
Terrace is a perfect person to talk
about this with she's the author of
several popular books and also a famous
textbook on psychology that you might
have used in your intro psych course way
back in the day other books include
psychobabble and bio bunked using
psychology to think critically about
issues in the news the mismeasure of
woman why women are not the better sex
the inferior sex or the opposite sex and
in September she has a new book coming
out called estrogen matters why taking
hormones and menopause can improve
women's well-being and lengthen their
lives without raising the risk of breast
cancer now I have to confess I'm not an
expert on either
sturgeon or menopause or hormones so
that's not what we're talking about in
this podcast but then again maybe that
is a mistake that I'm making that's what
we will be talking about how we make
mistakes so maybe I should read up on
estrogen and hormones that we can bring
dr. Travers back and have a conversation
about that today we're going to be
talking about cognitive dissonance and
why it makes us think that we never
actually really make mistakes so let's
start
[Music]
caryl Tavarez welcome to the mindscape
podcast very happy to be talking with
you so you're a social psychologist
right is that correct descriptor it is
as opposed to cognitive psych what are
what are the different kinds of
psychologist one could be all right
hardly anyone knows what a social
psychologist is they think you know
you're a therapist who gives a lot of
parties you know very social that's what
it must be social psychology was a field
born at the intersection of sociology
the study of groups and society and the
individual and fundamentally it is the
study of every social influence on human
beings which is to say everything
influences on how we think how we behave
influences of the environment on our
behavior influences of our thinking
culture the thing that's interesting
about social psychology to me is that
it's the field that really looks at
something that many Americans don't like
which is the idea that we really are
influenced by our environments in ways
that we don't realize and don't really
want to realize because after all we're
all individualist we make up our own
mind we're very independent American
dream the American dream so I always
found social psychology wonderfully
interesting and rich because there's no
topic it does not cover from love to
hate my dear co-author and very good
friend Elliot Aronson said that when he
was a student he was drawn to social
psychology because clinical psychology
is about repair but social psychology is
about change it's a more optimistic
approach to the world because by
understanding how we as individuals and
how what is happening in our world
influenced us we can actually take some
steps to improve things but you don't
see patients no you're not that would be
a clinical side that would be a clinical
psychologist so the field of psychology
and we actually speak about the
difference between the way clinical
are trained or I should say
psychotherapists are trained and the way
psychological scientists are trained
this creates what we speak of as the
scientist practitioner gap if you will
because many psychotherapists which by
the way is an unregulated word you know
you you could put out a shingle tomorrow
doing brocolli therapy and it would be
completely legal but at least don't do
that might do that broccoli not broccoli
really so psychotherapy anybody could be
anything and call themselves a
psychotherapist clinical psychologists
have a PhD in that field of clinical
psychology and their field is to study
psychological disorders and problems
their training varies from very good
scientific training to zero okay so the
rest of psychology the psychological
sciences if you will specify particular
areas of study so developmental
psychologists study development from the
infant to death social psychologists do
what I just described cognitive
psychologists study the mind thinking
memory and so forth so those are
different specialties within
psychological science but most people to
this day when they hear psychologists
they think you're a therapist yeah they
think that there's a couch and not just
a therapist by the couches have been out
for decades decades
nobody well there you go that's your
shingle your therapy can have the couch
if you want I don't how about chocolate
instead of broccoli toe therapy couches
candles the whole bit in our textbook
Carol Wade at the Carroll wide and I did
for so many years we actually proposed
chocolate immersion therapy as probably
the most beneficial thing you could
learn to damned ethical I could be
really rich we all have that problem
exactly and so you have various arrows
in your quiver I know you've written a
number of books but you've written one
of my favorite books of all time
mistakes were made but not by me
and this is on the subject of cognitive
dissonance so why don't you tell us a
little bit about number one you have a
co-author we already mentioned Eliot
arenson and how the book came to be and
what cognitive dissonance is in one
sentence or three you get all hours I
don't know any sentences
well so I guess first I should say what
cognitive dissonance is every social
psychology student learned this I did
when I was in graduate school a million
years ago it's a simple mechanism but
it's it's developed over the decades
into a really rich theory of
understanding why it is that when you
tell somebody in a kind and warm and
friendly way here's some information
that shows why you're wrong they rarely
thank you they tell you where you can go
with your findings and what you can do
with them and they're just not inclined
to be so you know my friends still say
to me to this day Oh Carol you're so
delusional II dare to think that just by
explaining to people here's an important
finding you need to know that they are
not always grateful so all the cognitive
dissonance really means is that it's the
uncomfortable feeling we have when two
ideas clash with each other conflict
with each other
it can be two ideas two beliefs or it
can be more commonly an attitude and
behavior so the classic example is
smoking a person who smokes knows that
smoking is dangerous and stupid so they
will be in a state of dissonance I smoke
but I'm doing something dangerous and
stupid this discomfort is cognitive
dissonance and Leon Festinger who
developed this theory in the late 50s
described it as being as uncomfortable
as being hungry or thirsty it's so
uncomfortable that you're really
motivated to reduce it in whatever way
you can well if you're a smoker you need
to quit smoking or you need to justify
smoking you need to say well it's
unhealthy
but I'll be thin and being thin is good
besides that Myrtle lived to be 97 look
cool I look really cool so cognitive
dissonance you know I I don't think I
took it terribly seriously I thought it
was really an interesting theory but I
didn't have much appreciation of its
depth of application and then after
George Bush got us into the Iraq war
Elliot and I were sitting
around talking about sorry which George
Bush in which Iraq war double yeah yeah
yeah 2003 so several years later when it
was abundantly clear that the
justifications for going into Iraq were
completely wrong there were no weapons
of mass destruction and so forth and of
course the whole country had noticed
that Bush did not say gee we were wrong
so sorry we made a really bad mistake
about spending a trillion dollars in
going into Iraq instead he found other
justifications for the war
well we're bringing democracy to the
region and so forth so Elliot and I are
having this conversation and he said you
know he said I disagree with those
Democrats who thought that Bush was
lying to the country he said I don't
think he was lying to the country I
think he was lying to himself he was
doing what all of us do when we have
made a decision to do something is we
screen out discrepant dissonant
information that suggests our decision
is wrong we focus we cherry-pick the
information that tells us our decision
is the right one and we go forth so we
make the decision and then we justify it
he said I think that George Bush had
made the decision to go into Iraq and
therefore ignored the arguments from his
own intelligence community that that
might not be a good thing to do and I
said my goodness I said and from that
conversation because that war was so
devastating to our country and so help
ibly wrong we thought well how do we
want to analyze this how do we want to
talk about this and from that
conversation came the idea to do a book
that would apply the many domains of our
lives in which the need to reduce
dissonance gets us into terrible
terrible trouble not just politically
but in our relationships in our
understanding of memory in therapy in
really every aspect of our lives right
yeah so one of the things we could do an
entire podcast on just this but your
book is filled with these wonderful
juicy examples of people being in
possession of an idea faced with new
information that conflicts with that
idea and coming up with a justification
so I have many questions but let's just
give a reward to our podcast listeners
by telling them some of these juiciest
examples in love in the law right in
like you said politics already doomsday
cults is one of the best well what do
mistake cults well doomsday cults yes
two filmmakers in England actually made
a little film about a doomsday guy who
predicted the end of the world doomsday
is particular particularly good story
because it was one of the stories that
got Leon Festinger involved with this
whole notion of cognitive dissonance
which was this he got involved with a
cult many years ago and sorry he was the
originator of the idea yes Leon
Festinger it was a social psychologist
at Stanford so what years are we talking
here in late 50s okay late 50s and
fasting her and two colleagues
infiltrated a doomsday cult in which a
woman whom they called Marian Keach
predicted that the world would end on
December 21st of that year and they they
joined this group now what they found
was when they joined the group they were
pretending to pretend we believers
pretending to be believers so there were
several people there were many people
who believed the world was going to come
to an end now if you believe the world's
gonna come to an end you could do one of
two things you could sit quietly in your
house and wait for the world to end or
you could proselytize you could sell
your house in your cow and go off and
live with Mary and ki John you know go
go be with her on the night of the great
event or chocolate immersion therapy if
you invent the doomsday cult I will
offer them this fine it's a lot
healthier and safer by the way of
doomsday cult so so they go to sit with
her on the night of December 21st
meanwhile her husband slept soundly
through the whole night having not
believed one single word of this
at 2:00 a.m. at 2:00 a.m. there's no
sign of any magic spaceship coming to
whisk them away and save them you see
they were going to be saved because they
understood that the world was coming to
an end no spaceship nothing's happening
what to do what to do and finally very
late mrs. Kitsch has a vision and the
vision is that the world has been saved
because of the devout belief of her
little band right this is a lot better
way to reduce dissonance between I just
made the stupidest mistake I could ever
have made what kind of an idiot
am I to have made this prediction this
allows you to think of yourself as a
smart kind and wonderful person and have
your prediction fail this is the essence
of what Eliot arenson did in advancing
the theory of dissonance by turning it
into a theory of self justification -
two ideas can be dissonant you know you
like Woody Allen films and your friend
doesn't like Woody Allen films and so
you might try to decide your friend as
it's okay to be stupid about what he
Allen films or whatever it might be but
the dissonance that most stings is when
information about a belief or something
that we've done directly causes us to
question our self-concept something
about ourselves that we feel is really
important about ourselves if you
criticize something about me that I
don't consider important or I don't
think I'm good at well so what you can
deal with that but if you show me how
I've not been skeptical about something
I really should have been skeptical
about I've let the gullibility take over
I'm going to be really embarrassed and
I'm going to try to reduce that
dissonance either by defending myself
and by dismissing the evidence that I've
been a gullible fool so that's why it's
so important to understand how
dissonance works because when the
self-concept is threatened I'm a good
worthy smart person and now you're
telling me
I've done something bad cruel harmful
and wrong well piss off and take your
information with you to me one of the
most important findings of this theory
is that it explains why people who are
good compassionate caring people will
often find themselves continuing
practices that are wrong harmful and
outdated precisely because they see
themselves as good kind compassionate
people I'm a doctor you're telling me
that this thing I've been doing in my
practice for 20 years is harming my
patients the hell it is I'm a good
competent doctor so I'm gonna keep doing
this and you give examples for example
of in the legal system
people being found guilty by prosecutors
but then obviously culpa Tory evidence
comes along clearly mistakes have been
made
and yet the people who did the
prosecution's are the detectives who
arrested the person in the first place
don't see it that way they do not
because they're the good guys by
definition prosecutors and police are
the good guys we're the ones in the
white hats and those bad people are bad
and now you're telling me that I a good
person put another good person in prison
well that's not even possible
therefore ok so if he didn't commit this
particular crime he certainly committed
other crimes and so but I'm not doing
anything wrong anyway I mean that truly
is their reasoning the the inability to
I mean of course there are many venal
and reasons that people might not admit
mistakes that's not what we're we're
talking about I mean people will fail to
admit a mistake because they don't want
to be fired they don't want to be fine
they don't want to go to prison I mean
that's those are obvious reasons that
people lie dissonance explains why we
lie to ourselves that's why it's so
pernicious and so dangerous and so
important to understand and so we've
done politics and
the law and doomsday cults love lights
marriages does it ever happened that we
are no okay one more thing about the law
though because this is so important
throughout the legal system and in the
military once people believe that they
are interrogating a guilty person
nothing that person does or says will
dis confirm their belief this is true of
the psychotherapists and social workers
who believe that they could tell if a
child had been sexually abused say if
the child admitted it while the child
had been abused but if the child denied
it while the child was in denial so
there was no way if you are convinced
that you know what has really happened
in a situation with a child or a suspect
or a a convict or anybody
everything that person does will confirm
your belief to make your belief
consonant with what you're doing it's
the way that many police officers are
even trained detectives are trained in
interviewing is if a suspect seems
nervous that's a sign of guilt what if
it's a sign of nervousness because
you've just been arrested and you're
innocent yeah there might be alternative
explanations which they are not trained
to think of that's right and and that
parallels what he said about George W
and the Iraq war and but clearly in our
it's not just high-stakes courtroom
dramas in our everyday lives and our
personal lives and marriages this is
going to be something where our partner
accuses us of a certain kind of behavior
maybe there's a twinge of truth to that
accusation and we're able to justify it
somehow yes we are aren't we yes yes
indeed well Elliot puts it this way he
said here's how it works he said you
fall in love and the person is the most
wonderful person it this person is just
adorable everything about this person is
a lovable thing you are in a state of
blissful consonance because everything
this person does conforms to what you
think the ideal partner should be
then a tiny blip occurs on the landscape
of love crabgrass in the lawn of life
whatever it might be and your beloved
turns out to have a habit that you
really don't like so much you know you
like getting places 20 minutes early and
your beloved likes to get there two days
late right this is okay now at first
what people do is just dismiss this
dissonant information about the
perfection of the beloved and say it's
really not important and most of the
time it's not but what happens next is
going to be key for how couples maintain
their relationship in the sense that all
of us do things that the other person is
annoyed by or doesn't agree with and
then the question is whether you come to
see those things as as behaviors that
are too dissonant to live with or
whether you reduce dissonance by saying
you know what this person is so
wonderful in so many other ways that
this particular problem is trivial and I
can live with this but those are the
negotiations we do all through our lives
you can see what happens when people
have made the decision to divorce is
that suddenly they they have a meant
they have a little memory surgery and
immediately forget everything they ever
once loved about the person and now
everything about the person is demonic
terrible and wrong and that I always
knew forever that this person was the
worst possible person well no you didn't
a switch flips right a switch flips and
the switch flips because now you are
seeking to be consonant in your view
that this person is too damn terrible to
live with any further and so everything
then gets rewritten to conform to the
news story in my book the big picture I
talked about similar ideas because I'm
trying to talk about some kind of
coherence in one's view of the world so
I introduced the idea of a planet of
belief
that you have a set of beliefs that are
kind of like rocks or asteroids that
come together under a mutual
gravitational pull because they seem you
know to fit together and you have you
develop a coherent view of how to look
at the world and this is your planet of
belief and these planets develop their
defense mechanisms right if something
comes along a stray rock from outer
space that threatens to undermine the
integrity of the planet you try to blast
it out of space right you don't try to
fit it in necessarily and it's very
interesting waha logical dissonance here
I think it's very interesting I mean you
might say given these examples why don't
people just change their minds right is
it just a matter of it's too much work
like why don't they get a new worldview
is it is it all about status and their
self-image or does it go deeper than
that well it's both of those things it
depends what the world view is about in
in particular so and how important it is
to you whether this is really a
worldview that governs how you see the
world and how you behave in that world
and we all have our narratives as the
trendy word now is our stories that
govern our lives as george gerbner once
said we're the only species that tells
stories and lives by the stories we tell
that's really the key thing so for
example if we can see this with with
memories everybody comes up with a story
of their lives
I was raised this way this is the kind
of person I am this is what happened to
me that has made me what I am today
that story is often a very powerful one
because it explains to us who we are so
now I come along and say to you you know
what that memory you have of what your
father did to you and you were seven
turns out that didn't happen at all that
way and it's jarring it's jarring to
learn that a memory you have that seems
to fit the story you tell about your
life isn't so that's why we get so upset
to learn that our memories are fallible
and are wrong
so as I said earlier in Elliot's view
about the dissonance that hurts the most
is the dissonance that most blows up the
planet if you will that most questions
something we've so we've lived by
whether it's religion or atheism or a
life story a belief about why we are the
way we are
and moreover where it's not just
changing one idea but chain but where
one idea is gonna pull out a thread
that's gonna unravel the whole thing so
these ideas of cognitive dissonance it's
slightly different but clearly related
to cognitive biases that we have right
the little bugs in our reasoning
capacities that motivate us to think one
way or the other motivated reasoning my
brain is not giving me any cognitive
bias you don't tell my head confirmation
by is well that's the key one well
cognitive dissonance is based on and I
want to say that this is a theory of
mental functioning that has more than
2,000 experiments supporting it in every
aspect of social and cognitive
psychology it has a lot of evidence
underlying it and one reason is that
that the component cognitive biases
really are subsumed under it in a way
that is cognitive dissonance rests on a
number of particulars one is the
confirmation bias which we might call
the consonance bias I'm going to look
for information that confirms what I
believe and will keep me in a state of
consonants and I'm gonna dismiss and
throw out and tell you you're a jerk and
if you give me infinite evidence that's
dissonant right so the confirmation bias
is key to how we keep our thoughts
consonant there's the the bias that
we're not biased that is a very good
bias I really love that bias the Rosses
I don't have that bias I think it is the
cutest bias ever but you see if you
think how it plays out you and I are
having an argument I am an unbiased
person therefore if I can just sit here
and tell you why you're wrong and I'm
right you will understand that you are
wrong and I am right and that will be
fine because you are biased and I'm not
and we'll have a lovely country only I
understood that progress will be made
there you go and the fact that you do
not accept what I have told you and
instead have your own beliefs so
unthinkable that means you're biased and
I'm not I mean it's it's a central
filter of how we get through our days
and it is the reason that quarrels and
arguments not only continue but escalate
because the determination to show that
other person why they're wrong why
they're wrong and you're not continues
so many of the information biases that
govern us in a way can be subsumed under
this overarching need to be consonant to
keep our beliefs uniform and motivating
I mean motivated reasoning is is exactly
the more recent term for this as Elliott
says every few years somebody renames
dissonance theory something else so that
they can get their publications and to
show why it's not cognitive dissidence
at all is there newton thing well that's
the same thing so I mean in some sense
this is we'd rather be coherent than
right mm-hmm
that's what how our brains work anyway
you wouldn't say that out loud but sort
of under the hood this is the machinery
working to make everything smooth out
remove the conflicts wherever we can yes
and and we would add that that is
evolutionarily speaking a very adaptive
strategy you don't want to keep changing
your mind four times before breakfast
you don't want to sit there saying
mm-hmm should I brush my teeth although
then you read a study of flossing and
you think you know I'm just being a
silly but if we had to change our minds
with everything that came along every
day we wouldn't get anything done and so
we choose what kind of package of
beliefs we want to hold and for the most
part spend our energy following those
then
then investigating every new thing that
might cover simply there's some
evolutionary pressure to be correct
about the world also but there is
clearly a trade-off right somehow
whether it's there might be some physics
explanation for this I'm not sure some
Bayesian reasoning some efficiency some
thermodynamics explanation but coherence
I'd like you say somehow the coherence
of the worldview has been so important
as we've gone through the generations
that that is is almost utmost when we
try to make sense of the world well
that's right and of course so many of
the things that evolved to suit us when
we lived in tribes little little bands
were effective ways of keeping us rooted
to and connected to our tribe mates and
of course the corollary of that is that
anyone who is not in our tribe was an
enemy who had to be stomped out
immediately their boots are definitely
wrong okay so happy you've all passed
that yes indeed so those were you know
adaptive strategies for thinking and
behaving but they don't always service
well today and you pointed out that
there's almost an inverse correlation in
our ability to deal with these cognitive
biases with how smart somebody is their
intelligence or their level of self
esteem if the better you are at
reasoning the better it turns out you
are at reconciling these distances in a
way that doesn't change your mind oh not
reconcile better at justifying
justifying it justifying yourself yeah
yeah exactly it's you know it's it's
your most skeptical skeptics I've been
gullible or the people who think of
themselves as being most competent in a
particular sphere who are going to
resist being told they put an innocent
kind prisoner they've just killed the
patient and so forth of course I want to
make it clear there are many many
exceptions of people who really want to
improve how they do their jobs and how
they live in the world but they are not
generally the majority I would like to
mention because I find so many people
have found this
for to be really helpful in their lives
so I'll mention it now we call it in the
book the pyramid of choice and as I say
it's been very touching to me to find
people have written and said I mean this
really works for me so it started
because somebody did a study a long time
ago of school children there were kids
and this question is what's your view of
cheating so imagine a pyramid or a
triangle if we're two-dimensional you're
at the top of this pyramid and your
views you you and your pal have the same
views of cheating you don't think it's a
great thing to do but it's not the worst
crime in the world okay you're neutral
about cheating now you're taking a test
it's really an important test it's the
final exam your grade is gonna depend on
this exam we all know how students are
if I don't pass this everything will go
south my cat will leave me you know
you've seen this an exam my world will
end okay but you freeze on a crucial
question you do not know how to answer
this question you're great is gonna
you're gonna fail this is horrible
and suddenly the student next to you
makes her answer abundantly clear and so
you have in one second cheat or don't
cheat no so in this study some of the
kids were given a situation which they
were able to cheat and some not so forth
and here's what they found the second
you make that decision even impulsively
you cheat some you cheat because the
grade is really important you don't
cheat because your integrity is more
important now the minute you make that
decision you must make your behavior and
your belief about cheating consonant so
if you cheat your attitude will now
shift to be cheating is really not such
a bad thing everybody cheats it's not
important and I'll never cheat again if
you resist the impulse to cheat you say
wait a minute
cheating is not a victimless crime we
all suffer from it it's a terrible thing
cheaters are bad so in our in our
metaphor of this pyramid you make that
first step down the pier
you cheater you don't cheat over time
what happens is you become more and more
entrenched in your view of cheating is a
good thing or a bad thing until over
time you are both at the bottom of this
pyramid standing far apart from each
other in your views about cheating the
one who cheated will think it's
completely trivial and not important at
all in the one who resisted will want to
hang you by your ankles outside the
school door having started almost the
same beliefs to having started exactly
and what's really interesting about this
when you visualize it you can see how
difficult it is to go back up and say
wait a minute
I was wrong to cheat and that's why I
mean there are many metaphors for this
with slippery slope and so forth but it
by seeing it in a dissonance way in a
self-justification way you can see how
hard it becomes to go back and say you
know that little jump that little random
thing I did has led me far from what my
original views of cheating were so that
metaphor applies to so many decisions
that we make in our everyday lives from
an impulsive decision somebody's accused
of rape or accused of some other
horrible act and what do we do as
citizens reading the newspaper or the I
did I just say reading the newspaper
please forgive me what is it newspaper
okay but we are listening to the pot
this noon to the podcast we all make
impulsive decisions that person's guilty
or that person's innocent and then we
don't want to hear we don't want to wait
for god forbid evidence
oh please suggesting that we're right or
wrong and so we see these in today's
world where everybody instantly jumps to
an opinion about everything without
necessarily waiting for evidence or
further information and that's how
quickly you can get a meshed in
justifying that initial jump off the
pyramid and when you turn out to be
wrong not so easy to say I love the
pyramid of choice I think I'm in the
who once you explained it to me was like
oh my goodness that just explains so
many things you know the faculty at Duke
University when that lacrosse team was
accused of raping the stripper that
they'd hired and so forth and the the
faculty 80 members of the faculty took
out a full-page ad saying you know the
culture of the rape culture of our
athletic teams and so forth is
disgraceful da da da
in other words assuming that the
allegations against the team were
accurate and when they turned out not to
be and when they were false yeah they
were false and when the district
attorney was disbarred for not sharing
appropriate information with the defense
was there a letter from the faculty
saying gee we made a mistake you know we
shouldn't have been so quick to judgment
maybe we should have waited for the
evidence it's been that many letters in
history yeah I this is related to what
I'm sure is a cognitive bias I've not
seen it talked about in psychology or
whatever but when dealing with
probabilities human beings are very bad
at estimating probabilities but also
they're very bad at accepting that
probabilities go from zero to 100% right
I think that when faced with something
that might happen you're not sure it's
gonna happen it seems to me people will
only really deeply accept three
possibilities that the chance of this
thing happening is zero present that
it's not gonna happen that it's a
hundred percent it's definitely going to
happen or that it's 50 percent though we
have no idea whether it will happen or
not the idea that it's 70 percent and
that sometimes the 30 percent thing
happens I think that Nate Silver got in
a lot of flak after Donald Trump got
elected because he gave something like a
70% chance that Hillary Clinton would
get elected and afterward he was like
that wasn't wrong like 30 percent things
happen all the time and but we we have
this inability I think to correctly
judge probabilities that are not 50/50
or 1 or 0 does that make sense
absolutely well and it's completely true
and of course as we know when people
make decision
medical decisions right do I want this
treatment it has a 10% chance of success
and a 90% chance of failure I mean we
are asked to make medical decisions
often on the basis of likelihood right
and risks and it's very hard to very
often to make those decisions or we look
at the the chance of something happening
rather than the chances of it not
happening so that's a that's a difficult
skill to acquire but truly an important
one a lot of poker players have become
very wealthy off of people's inability
to correctly judge these probabilities
and probably also the same the pyramid
of choice also feeds into the idea of
not only how we justify our own believes
but how we view others you know our this
goes back to the couple's of divorcing
right like you were in love with this
person at one point now you decide you
want to be with them anymore and they're
now Satan and talking to other people
about them afterward must lead these
people to say well why were you ever in
love with this person right but it
helped but but you change how you view
the other you change that's right well
what you say we have this guy in our
book was a friend of Elliott's who
having left his wife of 37 years said to
her said to her I never really loved you
well right so I just found online this
thing has just been going around how
Democrats and Republicans view each
other so not how they view themselves
but how they think actually that's I
think the study did ask how they view
themselves but who cares about that
those are more or less accurate but they
ask questions you know they ask
Republicans what percentage of Democrats
are agnostics or atheists the correct
answer is about 9% and the answer given
by Republicans was 96 percent 36 percent
yes some reasonability there the one I
liked was how many Democrats are gay or
lesbian and 38 percent is the average
Republican thinks over 1/3 of Democrats
are gays or lesbians and the correct
answer is closer to 6%
and the same thing for blacks and union
members it's but to be very very honest
the Republicans bad ideas about
Democrats were less crazy than Democrats
bad ideas about Republicans so how many
Republicans are 65 or older Democrats
thought it was 44% of Republicans are
over the age of 65 even a small amount
of thinking probably the numbers don't
really work out that way right it's
closer to 20% and my favorite how many
Republicans they also thought
Republicans tend to be evangelical
southerners but they also thought the
Republicans earned over $250,000 a year
the average Democrat thinks that 44% of
Republicans earn more than $250,000 a
year and the real number is two percent
not 44% and partly misinformation but it
has to be partly part of the cognitive
dissonance story right like we tell a
caricature and story of the people we
disagree with that makes us look better
yes well yes I mean that you've packed a
lot into that those answers stem from
stereotypes that we have of another
group a group that we don't know much
about I mean I remember reading a story
about some New Yorker who had moved to
Idaho
and everybody in Idaho thought he was
well you can imagine what they thought
of him and sort of a crazy liberal
Jewish communist pinko gay guy right I
don't know but the people in Idaho had
no experience with New Yorkers they know
nothing about New Yorkers and he goes to
Idaho with plenty of assumptions and
expectations about people and I know
they're all gun toting idiots or
whatever the hell that he thought they
were and what happens when you have
people living in the same community who
have different opinions is that you see
diversity in attitudes and behavior
amongst them my good friend and
co-author Carol Wade who lives in
Northern California
in a very gun-toting conservative area
but she said we disagree politically but
we see each other as the real human
beings that they are I see Republicans I
disagree with but they are caring
members of their community and they are
active in feeding the poor and the
hungry and they would stop by the side
of the road if you were in any kind of
trouble to help you and so it's not
stereotype thinking so what asking
questions like this of Democrats and
Republicans is asking about a stereotype
right or something about that group that
you don't like they're rich they're gay
they're crazy what if I was just abused
that Democrats thought that so many
Republicans were at once really rich and
also have angelical coherence do not
enter into stereotyping you should know
that by now but yeah and I think that
maybe does this help also explain I
don't want to open the Pandora's box but
social media and how vitriolic things
are and how we respond viscerally and
badly to the slightest amount of
disagreement online because we don't
appreciate the humanity of the people
behind the words right it's not a
face-to-face conversation all you're
seeing is this one little snippet of
belief or opinion and you can react
instantly and badly to it it's kind of
safe well but he counts to ten let alone
150 right you know the first book I
wrote anger the misunderstood emotion a
very long time ago was an examination
and part of the catharsis hypothesis the
idea that it's really good and healthy
to express your anger when you feel
angry and it will reduce your heart rate
then it will you'll prevent you from
getting ulcers and all kinds of other
good things wrong this was my first
experience with explaining kindly to
people why these clinical assumptions
and Freudian notions about catharsis not
only we're wrong but harmful because the
more people express anger the angrier
they get generally speaking and it
doesn't calm you down it riles you up
and so forth and in that book and
everyone instantly agreed and as you can
I had wonderfully interesting evidence
and of course as you can see thanks to
the diminution of anger in our society
that everybody that was your phone
Thanks yes so no they told me what I
could do with my ideas about catharsis
one guy wrote to me and said when my
wife densed the car I want to yell at
her I want to yell at her I wanted to
feel even worse than she does please so
this one researcher had identified the
conditions under which the expression of
anger is likely to be cathartic that is
to make you feel good conditioners oh
yeah
the first is no retaliation from the
target right so you say to your I agree
sweetie
you are a toad and the target says
you're right you know I really am it
okay so if there's no retaliation
that's good game you are anonymous so
the target can't respond to you your
anger is proportional to the offense so
if somebody does something trivial and
you hit them with a howitzer you're
gonna be embarrassed it sort of overkill
but if you feel your responses the
appropriate righteous thing you're gonna
feel good so that's the the gist of
these conditions all of which are met by
the internet you get to just rant
immediately you get to zap somebody you
get to be self righteously satisfied I
showed that person what's what and once
again people just failed to take my
advice about this you know I wrote I
remember writing a letter to a columnist
Russell Baker who was funny guy and he
wrote something that I disliked about
the women's movement I don't even
remember what it was and I wrote him an
angry letter I was terrific let me tell
you I was funny and smart and stupid
because you know how you feel when you
were writing something in anger hmm so I
send him this letter and he sent it back
to me edited he had written in the
margins and commented and basically of
course I get this thing back and I
realize how really rude I'd been and how
I was not gonna persuade him of anything
in my rudeness and so then I replied I'm
sorry this is not what I meant to say
let's try again
I sent him that one and he wrote back
and said I think this could be the
beginning of a lovely and civilized
correspondence it was a great lesson for
me because with anger there's two
reasons to be enraged one is you want to
punish the other person and the other is
you'd like to change the other person or
fix the problem between you and a lot of
people confuse those motives I think and
this brings us to the question of what
can we learn from cognitive dissonance
theory about how to actually change
people's minds if that were to be our
goal I think as you're implying
sometimes that's not our goal sometimes
we just want to let loose that's right
and maybe we should squelch that impulse
but sometimes you want to reach people
knowing that people are defensive about
their existing views and knowing that
they want to justify themselves does
that give us a clue as to how to be
better persuaded it gives us a very
important clue one that's not always
successful of course we can do better
with our own views perhaps than trying
to change the other guys but the the
rule the guiding rule number one is do
not make the other person feel stupid
for what they believe and this is of
course what people do what's the matter
with you what were you thinking when you
did that how could you spend $5,000 on
magazine subscriptions you know what are
you an idiot well what is the person
gonna say you have now exquisitely put
them in a terrible state of dissonance
between I'm a smart person I spent these
money this money on magazine
subscriptions because I'm hoping I'll
win the lottery and my children will
have money forever my motive was a good
one
so when you make people feel stupid for
believing what they believe you
guarantee that they will hold on to that
belief even more strongly you've just
guaranteed it so instead you
you look to understand or talk to the
person about why they believe what they
do what did what that belief serves for
them how it helps them whether they
themselves see any problems with it
whether they see a better way of getting
what it is they want so that you don't
make it an adversarial I'm right and
you're wrong because that one's gonna go
nowhere for me Anthony pin who's another
podcast guest talks about giving people
a soft landing he talks about why
certain communities have different
beliefs that they do and he said well
you know what all you're telling them is
that they're idiots and that they're
irrational they don't understand the
reason in evidence and no one has ever
been really persuaded by that that's
exactly right
he's he's put it exactly in dissonance
terms if you're gonna make me feel
stupid I'm out of here
and by the way it may be that the
accuser we the smart questioner really
don't understand what that belief is
serving for the other person what they
gain by believing as they do how it
comforts them how they've lived by it
how much investment of time and
emotional energy they've put into that
belief one of Elliott's classic
experiments severity of initiation on
liking for the group it's a famous funny
study but basically what he found is
that the more work and paying an effort
you put into joining a group the more
you're gonna like that group even if it
turns out to be really a stupid and
uninteresting group so all of us have
beliefs that we have spent a lot of time
and sometimes sometimes pain as well and
investing I think for ourselves in
understanding dissonance the story we
tell in our book which which I just love
because I think it's a it's such a good
guideline for us all is this is a true
story when Ronald Reagan went to Bitburg
Germany to lay a wreath there at the
cemetery where it turned out that 47
Nazi officers had been buried there was
an enormous protest over this he's going
to this cemetery and honor
these Nazi war dead and Reagan's good
friend shimon peres
then Prime Minister of Israel was of
course particularly outraged so were
many others around the world but Reagan
didn't back down so someone asked Peres
how do you feel about the fact that your
good friend Ronald Reagan went to
Bitburg to do this ceremony and Paris
said when a friend makes a mistake the
friend remains a friend and the mistake
remains a mistake that is the goal in
how we ought to think about cognitive
dissonance because the usual impulse
friend has made a mistake is to drop the
friend or minimize the mistake you can
see this in news reports all the time
somebody we really think as a fabulous
person has been convicted of some crime
or accused of something and we really
you know people don't know which which
way to which way to go I know that guy I
know that's so sweet doesn't sound like
him at all exactly or or you know the or
the mistake please what he did oh it's
just trivial you know 43 children really
you know so that's the usual thing that
we do and we usually do that
unconsciously
we make those those reductions of
dissonance under the radar to allow
ourselves to feel comfortable because
living with dissonance is painful I want
to go back to that point it's really
uncomfortable Sarah Silverman has a
fantastic three-minute video that she
did when her good close friend louis c.k
was discovered to have been committing
these right awful sexual acts and she
heard her video is a perfect statement
of a person and dissonance she says what
he did was wrong it disgusts me and I
hate it but he's been my very good
friend for many years I know what a
great humanitarian he is what a great
father he is what a great friend he's
been so she
able to separate these two things and
she said I don't know where I'm gonna
resolve this but that that's the
struggle that's worth doing rather than
throwing him under the bus or minimizing
his actions it's harder it's harder it
seems to me like empathy is important
here I know Paul blooms psychologist who
I'm hoping to get as a future podcast
guest he wrote a book he had a brilliant
idea that's right a book called against
empathy empathy is bad and very very
roughly speaking his idea is that it
having empathy tends to be something
that we do for people who are like us
and therefore too much empathy pushes us
away from the direction of reason and
rationality and thoughtfulness because
it just makes us instantly identify with
other people but it sounds like if we're
really trying to understand people who
seem to be doing something we don't
understand ourselves putting ourselves
in their place understanding where they
came from
like you said understanding the reasons
why those beliefs are so valuable to
them would be useful to us well it is
the question is the consequences of
understanding you know the French say to
understand all this to forgive all no it
isn't to understand all this to
understand all period that's all it is
and then once you understand then you
can decide do I want to forgive is this
important to forgive does my
understanding give me greater compassion
for why this person has behaved as they
have and make me more forgiving of it or
not that's a separate question and
that's a moral issue a moral choice for
each of us but we all live by the
attributions we make of other people's
behavior this is another big part of
social psychology which is how the
explanations we make of why people do
what they do effects everything so if
you think your beloved has been rude to
you or thoughtless because your
beloved's had a horrible day at work and
in Los Angeles a 19-hour commute home
okay you'll be more forgiving than if
your attribution is to their person
they're just the way they are and even
talking to people in public if we want
to say this person disagrees with me is
it because they have a principled
objection to what I'm saying or just
because they have bad motives and are
not acting in good faith and clearly
don't understand the force of my reason
exactly
well it's why the goal really of what it
means to be open-minded is to make
ourselves open to other people's points
of view without the the the dissonance
reduction reaction is get that other
point of view out of here I don't want
it in the room but when you can if you
have to make important decisions if you
can surround yourself with people who
aren't yay sayers who aren't just going
to agree with you but who might show you
where you might be wrong that's
extremely useful and then we have the
idea of persuading others we also the
idea of fixing ourselves right I I've
been in the crowd when you've given
talks to audiences Tam for example and
it's amazing you know you explained how
cognitive dissonance makes people
justify their mistakes and things like
that and everyone in the audience is
going yes the people I disagree with do
justify the mistakes that way and almost
no one says hmmm maybe I am justifying
my mistakes like what is there a toolkit
or a checklist or some set of strategies
we can have to notice when we're doing
this when we're doing this
self-justifying behavior sure you notice
that you're justifying we're so good
right at coming up with the excuse so
when it's an excuse and when is it just
a correct rational reconstruction of why
we're thinking in such a way oh well
that's a very fine question the one of
the things that's been interesting to
read the Amazon reviews of our book is
how many people say well I started out
reading this book as this explains all
my friends then halfway through it all
this explains the government too and
then at the end of it explains me I see
science in general as a form of
arrogance control
in the sense that it's one of them most
organized methods we have of forcing us
to put our beliefs to the test and
forcing us to face dissonance if the
test does not confirm what we believe
that's that's the method we have set up
to test our beliefs and you don't have
to do a scientific experiment to do that
to take some belief that you hold and
say well hmm really what is the evidence
for this is there you know it's the
evidence changing what I once thought to
be true
I look back on my writing and social
psychology and I'm it's interesting to
me how many ideas have have changed
irritatingly because the evidence has
changed or has become more persuasive I
do I personally agree that you know
acting as an informal scientist is a
good way to correct yourself against
some of these biases like you say much
of the scientific method informal and
crazy and non systematic as it is is
about putting off the possibility that
we will fool ourselves one way or the
other I'm always very amused as a
cosmologists as a physicist
if I say something about the Big Bang or
Einstein or relativity there's some
fraction of people out there in the
world who will say oh you're just
defending the establishment views of the
cosmos and I want to say you know all of
my incentives are in the other direction
right like you don't become a famous
physicist by saying that Einstein was
right was right the whole point the
whole you know incentive structure in
science is to say the great people of
the past were wrong and we can do better
than them and that's that's a wonderful
sort of self-corrective to try to do now
on the other hand at the same time I
realize I'm telling a flattering story
about myself because I'm saying that
scientists are the best at correcting
their false impressions because they
have this scientific training in them
well no scientists are human like
everybody else I think is that true I
mean aren't you guys law human being
there's a couple of outliers but yes
it's
even scientists are not always happy
that the results when results don't come
out the way they would like them to I
mean we all you know they'll say well
that I guess I didn't do that study well
enough you know I but I better redo that
another 45 times till it comes out right
right
the ideal scientists with we might all
aspire to but everybody knows the
feeling of thinking you know how can i
redo this so it will come out the way I
want it to come out that's certainly
empirically there's a million examples
of people yeah but indeed science is
self-correcting or at least it moves
forward in certain lurching ways fits
and starts and you're right people do
have an incentive to find something new
and different to say I mean you know and
in my field it's always so interesting
to me that all the studies that show
that similarities between women and men
and personality traits or abilities and
skills and so I mean that those never
get published it's the differences that
are sexy right want to know what what
differences there are and the news that
there aren't differences isn't news and
there isn't interesting but but the the
goal is to feel free enough to
investigate questions wherever they
might lead and one of the problems of
course we're facing in our polarized
society is that it's getting harder for
people to do that to question received
wisdom certainly in the social sciences
oh my god you know they ask provocative
questions to be a naysayer - right
you mentioned the brain did I've also
about I think you mentioned the brain I
think you just did maybe I projected it
onto you I don't know we've been talking
in Psychological terms of course there's
the sexy thing going on right now which
is the neuro scientific way of talking
about these things actually looking in
the brain not just talking to the person
but doing fMRI or M eg studies of what's
going on inside their head do these
concepts of dissonance and justification
map on to parts of the brain is that a
something that we aspire to or we can
say now or
is just crazy yes yes and no yes a
number of researchers have tracked
cognitive dissonance into the brain they
find out which parts of the brain are
lighting up light lighting up I love
that language lighting up is that's an
artificial light up but ok when the
brain is in a state of dissonance one of
the cutest experiments was to have
Democrats and Republicans process
information about their favorite
political candidate positive information
about their favorite candidate positive
information about the opponent
oh that's dissonant okay bad information
about your guy you know and when they
were in a state of dissonance my guy did
something bad the other guy did
something good you could see you could
see it in their brains and he said they
said it was like when consonance was
restored it was like twirling a whirling
a mental kaleidoscope to get the pieces
to fit right people really were happy
when the pieces fit right that said I
don't know what we've learned from this
that we didn't know otherwise and I'm
very interested in brain research of
course but I've also written about
pseudo neuroscience which is the notion
that if we just have a brain in there
we're really doing science and very
often a lot of those studies are just
somebody's got a scanner and I'm gonna
do what I can with it I love the term
neuro bollocks temptation to find things
going on in fMRI and what do you know
now that you didn't know before
now of course neuroscience is very
important but it's also hard to do right
right and maybe it's a little bit easy
to over claim what you're getting oh yes
of course it is oh of course it is and
you know it's not really like all new
technologies you know give a boy a
hammer and everything needs pounding
give researchers a scanner and
everything that needs scanning but what
am I looking for
and it's very early days we don't you
know we're pre Galileo right we're
trying to collect data understand that
the brain is way more complicated in the
solar system ever was but you also
mentioned or talked about the idea of
memories
and how memories aren't always accurate
and this is something that I first came
to from neuroscience from studies
actually from I was studying the arrow
of time the difference between the past
in the future and there is these
wonderful studies and I don't pretend to
be able to judge the scientific
credibility of various neuroscience
studies maybe it is neuro bollocks but
here's what the study said that if you
put someone in fMRI machines so you're
basically taking pictures of where the
blood is zooming around in their brain
and you ask them to imagine a past
experience remember what it was like in
your birthday last year wasn't you where
you were having dinner or whatever
certain parts the brain light up in
excitement because you're turning around
memory remembering this scene and then
you ask them to imagine the future scene
imagine what your next birthday will be
like near somewhere else and so forth
the claim was it's exactly the same
parts of the brain that are doing the
same thing of course they're doing
something different but evolution is
sort of cheap right evolutionary uses
things that are that are already there
maybe the hypothesis goes the way that
we learned to imagine the future is by
taking advantage of the fact that we had
a part of the brain that could remember
the past and just putting it to use
again and the idea being that the memory
of the past is not a video tape right
it's not a recording that is stored as a
JPEG file or an MPEG file somewhere it's
more like a screenplay and when we
remember the past we download the
screenplay and put the play on again
just like we do when we remember the
future well we imagine the few no it's
more like it's more like cells of a film
where you have a you have a couple of
those cells of a film and you are you
are interpolated
the connecting elements in a strip of
film in a film strip which I didn't mean
to interrupt you but I would say
something a little different which is
when you're asking them to remember a
past a childhood birthday or imagine a
future one you're you're imagining both
of those things you don't know that the
recall of the birthday is is accurate
what you're asking for is tell me a
story about what that birthday is that
you think you remember
you're not actively or accurately
retrieving every detail about that 5th
birthday party you have a few details
about it you've seen pictures of it your
mother's told you what the color of the
cake was you know or whatever it might
be
mostly you've seen pictures of it and
heard stories about it and so you've
made up a little memory of your fifth
birthday party that may or may not be
true and by the way every time you talk
about your fifth birthday party you're
going to embellish it and with every
embellishment your memory of it will
change and you reinforce first the
newest story yes exactly it's why it's
it's why it's so dissonant for people to
writ to accept the evidence that memory
is fallible in these ways and it's we we
keep our memories consonant with whom we
think we are now I mean my brother might
I had an older half-brother who had a
terrible stepfather who was really
pretty mean to him and Bill's memory of
his stepfather was how Mina's stepfather
was to him and all the time and he could
tell you these stories but years later
when he confronted his stepfather about
it the stepfather was you know
disciplinarian and cold the stepfather
said but you were a difficult kid you
didn't listen you didn't want to talk to
me about reasons for things I had to be
a strict disciplinarian with you because
otherwise you'd go headfirst out the
window and get into more trouble
my brother had written out of his
memories his own part in the story and
that's a common thing that we do so in
that way he created a story about how
his stepfather was mean to him and made
him do this that the other thing so past
and future you know as is a lovely arrow
but what we know about memory is well
you know with with all the research on
how unreliable memory is I think it's
important to say it's also pretty damn
good
right over all over all over I'm glad I
have one random I'm losing it rapidly so
I'm glad what remains I'm happy for it
but but
that is a hard thing for us I think to
understand that it's more efficient for
the brain to jettison elements of an
event or a memory that we really don't
need to have and to give us the gist the
center piece of it but it's also what
allows us to rethink events that
happened and to reconsider their causes
or other things that were happening at
the time and it was interesting to me to
realize that utterly false memories can
be just as vivid and just as absolutely
convincing to the remember as accurate
ones so it's so I guess oh people hate
that people are wrong right but it's
wrong to have a metaphor in your mind of
like a photograph that is aging and and
getting blurred out over time you could
have a very crisp very vivid very
believable memory that is a hundred
percent false exactly and so that's the
brain is doing something crazy there I
mean it's not just a that's what I mean
it's not - JPEG image in your brain
you're somehow sharpening up and and as
we said telling the story over and over
again I think this is gonna be part of
my chocolate immersion therapy tell
yourself the story you want to hear just
keep repeating it you know tell yourself
this version of the conversation you
just had which you come out victorious
pretty soon you'll forget it wasn't the
version that actually happened I think
that's very effective therapy I think
it's a very effective therapy the French
have an expression you know l'esprit to
scale yay the wit of the staircase which
is the witty deft retort that you think
of making as you're leaving the party
and walking down stairs
exactly we can only recreate that memory
to have be it something you said at the
time I live in fear of this and I live
in here that I'm gonna have be regretful
that I didn't ask you a whole bunch of
more questions but Carol Travers thank
you very much for being on this podcast
and a pleasure thanks Sean
[Music]
you
[Music]